i feel we are overusing the resources of
our planet
we want to expand the possibilities of
agriculture in an environment where it
wasn't thought that you could actually
grow plants
we think that that can really change the
outlook for the future
[Music]
[Music]
nemo's garden is an alternative
agriculture project
where we're trying to
find a way to grow plants underwater in
underwater greenhouses
we have grown between 50 and 60
different species
basil different kinds of salads goji soy
sprouts medical herbs
harvesting the plants is
actually very simple we cut it just like
we would do on land and then we wrap it
into
reusable plastic containers and we just
close it up and we
pick it up on the surface nice and
comfortable
the main challenges of growing plants
underwater are has never been done it's
all new initially the learning curve was
very steep every operation has to be
done scuba diving that is a challenge on
itself
the main advantages are the protection
from outside elements we are underwater
nothing can get to us no pests
means no chemicals needed and of course
no hail no storms
the temperature stability that we have
inside the water which is a lot more
stable than outside plus the higher
pressure underwater
apparently makes our plants grow faster
and stronger and with higher contents of
essential oils
the water that we use for the plants is
mostly from evaporation of the surface
of the salt water once it's evaporated
it condenses back into rain we basically
create fresh water automatically that we
don't need to consume any energy for
we know that climate change and and the
future of demography is headed towards a
way where we will be overusing the
resources of our planet
i hope the nemo's garden is a way to use
those resources in a very respectful way
and balanced way
the whole concept for the project is to
expand the possibilities of
agriculture
in a world that is covered more than 70
in water it simply makes sense to us